underway around the world including
right here in Las Vegas and this weekend
the Vietnamese Community will be holding
festivities to highlight the Year of the
Cat here tell us more is Shane Nguyen
and patronia pool Swan who are with the
Vietnamese American community of Las
Vegas welcome to the show thank you for
having us yeah it's great to have you
guys so let's start with the difference
between so with Chinese we have the year
of the rabbits in the year what's the
difference so there's an old saying the
reason the I'll answer's sister chose uh
the cat was because they need to have
the cat to chase all the mouse all the
lights out okay very traditional so back
to the days of people working in the
rice fields yes and the cat's there to
help out the family so we celebrate the
cat and there's a big celebration this
weekend yeah tell us about it yeah so
it's this coming Sunday yeah the 29th
from three to seven at the YMCA near
Meadows mall and we will have Dragon
Dance yes face painting yeah traditional
out yeah
yeah so it's basically you know it's
Vietnamese Community put this together
to show that there's such a diversity in
the Lunar New Year celebrations right
not just the Chinese but also the
Vietnamese celebrated like the food
you're looking at here
you're telling me there's meaning behind
some of the food here so what do we have
right here so Shane tell us so this is
that right here
um so it takes roughly 18 hours to make
uh this is uh but you were saying too
but also the part of the process is 18
hours is because you're getting families
together yeah they're spent time of New
Year so every New Year's first of all
our New Year's celebration is like the
biggest celebration in our country right
and some families celebrate for a week
some celebrate up to two weeks so so he
is a big part of the movie yeah to get
us together yeah get us together to make
it we have the pork sausage we have lots
of like candies and fruits and stuff so
all to bring kind of good luck and you
know to honor our ancestors yeah and
another thing we like to give out is the
the Elder always give this uh least C
which is there's money in there to
spread out the luck to the younger okay
kids and also the giver also get the
luck as well by giving so we put three
babies red envelopes so you put money in
the envelopes to hand them out okay I'll
say kids I'm saying okay what about Kim
JC if you're younger older people can
give it but that's a beautiful tradition
so you give this and also if you're
giving the money to the child you're
also receiving good luck in return
exactly yeah that is fantastic receiving
love how can people get involved this
weekend just come out and enjoy the
festivities what's great about this
event is it's completely free for
everyone yes come out people of all ages
you don't have to be Vietnamese you get
to come celebrate the Vietnamese
Traditions as part of Lunar New Year
we're about to see the entertainment
here what are we going to see real fast
so this is a northern part of Vietnam
traditional folk dance that year that
you're about to see perfect this is live
entertainment part of what we're going
to be seeing that day take it away a lot
of these dances
[Music]
foreign
at the Phil and Henrich YMCA Jillian
we'll send it over to you